[Music]
joining another installment in the
Transformers franchise is the return of
a long-running comedy series a Flamin
Hot success story the end of a
coming-of-age show and a classic rt25
pick that will have you saying good
afternoon good evening and good night
it's always sunny around here I also
expect tomatoes to grow on this week's
what to watch Prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming opening in theaters
this week is Transformers rise of the
beasts this marks the seventh
live-action offering in the franchise
and is Loosely based on the computer
animated series Beast Wars Transformers
which ran from 1996 to 1999 and includes
a pretty fresh first season not to
mention a bunch of happy 90s kids to
build on that 90s connection another
reason to see this one is the fact that
it introduces three new factions of live
action Transformers the maximals
terracons and Predacons all robots that
transform into robotic animals let me
guess I had you at robotic animals no
well how about the fact that along with
live-action Stars Anthony Ramos and
Dominique Fishback the star-studded
voice cast behind some of the
Transformers includes Pete Davidson Ron
Perlman Peter Dinklage Michelle yo and
of course Peter Cullen aka the longtime
voice of Optimus Prime is this a
bathroom
yes that's a bathroom you never told me
we had a toilet it's not a good one
we're fishing cans Charlie serving up
its 16th season premiere this week is
the hit show It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia if you're looking for a
good reason to check out this comedy
series how about 15 of them as in it has
15 fresh Seasons under its belt already
you heard that right 15. and for being
picky which I think we are seven of
those 15 are a hundred percent on the
Tomato Meter I think you get the point
and while this may be the longest
running live-action American comedy
series at season number 16. that doesn't
mean the end is anywhere near with
renewals already taking it through
season 18 at least so you know that if
you get hooked it won't be the last call
time anytime soon Plus for those not in
the know it's worth mentioning that it's
always sunny which one of People's
Choice Award for best cable TV comedy in
2016 was created and developed by Rob
mcelhenney and Glenn Howerton who also
Star as part of the show's hilarious
ensemble cast that critics and the shows
called following just can't get enough
of spicy see that's how I got here dear
God please forgive me for the gang the
drugs the stolen cars what the heck man
let's move it hey he's
heating up your movie options is the
dramedy Flamin Hot and if you're
thinking to yourself hey that'd be fun
if it was actually about Flamin Hot
Cheetos well then gosh darn it you're in
luck because it totally is the film is
based on the Memoir of Richard Montanez
a Frito-Lay janitor who'd claim to have
invented the Flamin Hot Cheetos snack
and if you're hungry for reasons to
watch isn't already satisfied how about
that it was directed by Eva Longoria in
her feature directorial debut after
previously directing episodes of shows
like Jane the Virgin and blackish and
with 30 reviews and Counting for Flamin
Hot it is currently fresh on the Tomato
Meter top critic waiting Liu from Little
White Lies praised Longoria's efforts
saying she flexes her directorial
muscles with technical Flair and genre
Transformations we're finally seniors
and honestly I think we're doing pretty
great now that I've done the deed I can
focus on what's important
I think we've really grown to being the
poised Fearless women we always dreamed
we'd be another streaming option for you
this week is the fourth season premiere
of never have I ever now the main reason
to check this one out if you haven't
already is that it was co-created by
Mindy Kaling and is Loosely based on her
childhood it follows a modern day first
generation Indian American teenage girl
whose father dies suddenly adding to the
stress and worry of trying to be a
teenager and find her identity Now's the
Time to check it out since this marks
the show's final season with three very
certified fresh Seasons setting the
stage critics have praised the show for
its young cast and hilarious honesty as
it approaches The Angst of teenage
romance with frankness and charm
frankness and charm the world needs more
of that from the largest Studio ever
constructed it's The Truman Show yeah
good morning good morning oh and in case
I don't see you good afternoon good
evening and good night and finally
because you know we got to keep
celebrating rt25 this year our pick this
week is The Truman Show that's right
this comedy was released 25 years ago
this week sorry to say you're kind of
old plenty of reasons to revisit this
one especially because it has one of Jim
Carrey's finest performances he stars as
Truman a man who doesn't know that his
whole life is just one big reality TV
show the film's initial spec script was
inspired by an episode of The Twilight
Zone and the film evolved into a
heartfelt dramedy that earned three
Oscar nominations including best
original screenplay along with a strong
audience score The Truman Show has a
certified fresh 95 on the Tomato Meter
and one reason critics love it is that
while riding the wave of the reality TV
show boom in the U.S The Truman Show
eerily captured America's celebrity
culture Obsession and thirst for the
private details of ordinary lives yikes
true but yikes well there it is five
picks that will transform your weekend
from a good one into a great one maybe
be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to visit
rottentomayos.com for the latest updates
on scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large and seriously check out
the rt25 page where we're celebrating 25
years of Rotten Tomatoes you won't
regret it that's all for today fresh
family until next week stay fresh
foreign